[Music]
hi i'm alex i'm really and we're here to
try to make a cheesecake factory dish
based off the menu description hi i'm
donald moore my alex and riya try to
figure this out i'm here to show you
what actually goes into making one of
our most classic recipes at each and
every one of our restaurants
the rules of this challenge are we have
three clues but don't worry even if we
mess up we'll still have something to
eat because doordash will be delivering
the real dish at the end of the day for
us to compare our recipe to
so let's get started all right so today
we are making bambang chicken shrimp
bang bang bang bang
ooh loaded baked potato that sounds very
like that tasty meat it's so good so
much variety let's check out the
cheesecakes actually ooh
ultimate red velvet mango key lime
cheesecake
fancy
okay alex
we have to find thousands of shrimp okay
focus all right there it is okay how
much you get the shrimp so reading
through the description the dish sounds
really good but the description is also
a little vague and so
not quite sure
the exact ingredients that are gonna go
in this dish
we're definitely gonna have to
wing it
maybe we should start with our first
clue yeah oh
cards a clue card yes
they're emojis
a chili pepper
yeah it looks like a chili pepper a
coconut coconut salt and pepper
and peanuts
to be honest this didn't help me that
much
critical to the bang bang chicken and
shrimp is a curry cream sauce we take a
really good ginger that's fresh that we
peel and we mince then we add this
really sort of specific coconut milk and
this curry paste and the curry paste is
all these sort of aromatics and spices
and we add all together to make this
curry cream sauce i feel like bang bang
would have a lot of flavor right yeah
you're not gonna have like a bang bang
it's like bang bang
oh yeah we got our next clue
just in time
[Music]
what look
a phone wait i don't even know how to
use it
we can only ask him one question and it
is only yes no i was a little bit
lost what to ask him because i had
mediums of questions maybe we should ask
if the peanut butter is in the sauce
yeah
hello hello
who is this who's this
this is alex and riya
hi how are you this is donald the chief
culinary officer of the cheesecake
factory cool
well we're such big fans of the
cheesecake factory thank you we're
actually making one of the recipes now
the bang bang chicken and shrimp super
popular and we have a question for you
so is there peanut butter in the sauce
there is peanut butter that's correct
there is peanut butter in one of the
sauces in one of the sausages
okay
thank you so much thank you for your
help our pleasure
okay
one of the sauces okay
well at least we're half right bang bang
let's go with two songs okay so i'm
gonna bring more spices i don't know if
we're
two steps ahead or two steps back really
have you had any thoughts about the
other mystery sauce that we have to make
maybe like a sweet like brown sugar soy
sauce maybe
one of the hidden treats of the bang
bang chicken and shrimp is this spicy
peanut vinaigrette so we take this spicy
peanut vinaigrette which is a blend of
seasoned rice vinegar and soy sauce some
chili a little bit of seasoning and
really good peanut flavor and fresh
crust peanuts we blend all that up and
we drizzle it over bang bang chicken and
shrimp so you'll get this great contrast
i didn't think it was this difficult
just like cooking by looking at the
picture i wish we could get a couple a
couple of more pictures yeah can we get
just like a profile like a like a tinder
profile of this curry reid and i know
how to build a curry at least so we can
kind of go with our gut on that one but
as far as getting the exact right
ingredients i know we're gonna miss a
couple we know the peanut butter's in
there coconut milk
i need a redder color we need to get
that is not the same maybe that is not
the same color so alex was picking this
like red sauce and she was saying it's
sriracha but i taste it and sniff it and
eat but it's buffalo sauce
and i don't think usually people use
buffalo sauce in a thai curry wait are
you serious
there's no going in that's your call we
have one more clue
oh do we just get it we have to choose
oh this is okay very difficult either we
do
this plate of a lot of things or there's
plenty not a lot of spicy
i'm gonna go with a lot of things right
well let's just mix it up
nine
wow
that's awesome we make all of our own
spice mixes in our restaurants no
different from our seasoning salt that
we season the shrimp for in this recipe
take a bunch of sugar and peppers and
paprikas and onions and secret spices to
make this really good blend that we sort
of get the shrimp really crusted with
where they get sugary and caramelized
and they have this sort of sweet heat
which adds a nice contrast to the dish
all right our curry's bubbling
shrimp comes in
it's a little that's a lot of shrimp
oh should i try to make that sauce put
together this
little this little bit
so i'm gonna make a little slurry here
whoa
is that right
[Laughter]
some lime looks great it does yeah i'm
proud of us it's the taste let's see i
love it let's play let's plate it let me
check the phone maybe do other shoes
almost here
they will be here in five minutes five
minutes perfect great a little mount
mm-hmm our amount of rice
get it all on there
maybe i'll just put like a little more
rice on top so that it's peeking out
like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can take it wait one
pretty good okay
yeah
all right yay we did it okay oh yes
we'll see
yeah so i'm gonna go get it okay
hi here's your food thank you thank you
food is here
let's see moment of truth wow it's heavy
and big
oh man
okay oh let me play this yeah okay i'll
be right back
uh-oh
wow
look who i found
hello
how are you how are you i'm donald i'm
the chief calling after the cheesecake
crusher you did a great job did we yeah
it's pretty pretty close you are very
nice yeah
i'm dying to try my first curry with hot
sauce in it you've never had a thai
buffalo curry this will be a first but
maybe you've created something fusion
instagram versus reality
all right should we try it yeah let's
try it we have to try ours first okay
pretty good yeah peanutty lots of chili
peanuts i think the buffalo sauce just
gives it an extra kick you can't really
tell that it's fun it's a beautiful thai
curry with a little bit of america with
a little bit of americana buffalo
fusion i think if you taste the
difference between ours you'll get a lot
of contrast and texture
oh yeah
that apple
really comes through oh yeah in a nice
way oh that's really good and
the creaminess from all those layers of
the sauces you were talking about
and the bang bang comes from the heat so
you'll get a sweet bite a spicy sort of
bang bang
bang bang baby that's what you want we
have a special treat for you but you
were awesome at this challenge which was
very complicated there's 50 or 60
recipes and techniques that go into this
we want to bring you something for your
awesome efforts thank you what is it
i think i could guess
two cheesecakes
we have a godiva chocolate cheesecake
which actually is gluten-free and
totally delicious and we have our brand
new pineapple upside down cheesecake
which is
really really cool for me no
one for me
well thank you so much we had so much
fun and if you want to try out this
recipe yourself you can order the bang
bang chicken and shrimp from the
cheesecake factory on the door dash app